well speaking of someone that does or
does not exist I'm wondering for you do
you mourn JT Leroy because I know this
person was very real to you and I
wouldn't say they're dead in a sense I
know that there was a passing away in
terms of the story of the person but
doom warned them you know I recently saw
the scene from where they bring
Tinkerbell back to life and it's
everyone has to say we believe we
believe you know Peter Pan's crying it's
like we have to get you back and and the
audience there was a show and everyone's
like we believe we believe and
Tinkerbell can come back and I'm getting
so many emails addressed to JT and it's
like that line that the historian said
about bugs bunny he might not exist but
he lives
nothing ever feels as good as an
interaction through JT it just doesn't
it's kind of like nut broccoli will
never taste as good as caramel crunch
ice cream it just won't you know or
burnt caramel it's so he's and he's
still he's still there so I I I mourn
he was asbestos gloves to handle a
material that I couldn't otherwise touch
and I got very used to going into that
puppet to be able to express and there's
a way going into that puppet and being
in there I can get in deeper like a
psychic surgery when you know in the
Philippines when they go in and they
take out and it's chicken guts and
they're doing this psychic surgery
there's a way that I got into that habit
and it it just feels organic and normal
and wonderful that
when I'm now doing it on myself
without those asbestos asbestos gloves
it's harder and it doesn't feel as
normal to me it so I don't know if that
answers you but basically yes and he's
also still there okay I think people may
be in my opinion were unfairly upset
over I mean how many people have written
in a nom de plume and you've talked
about this and avatars in this day and
age of social media we all kind of have
this alter ego and if that's what you
needed to express this story this
sometimes I think that comments in an
article or are more fascinating than the
article itself so it was a con aimed at
the publishing industry it was the
writer taking control instead of letting
the publishers take control or advantage
of the writer but if shyness was partly
the reason for the con can't she be
forgiven well the thing is I don't like
the word con like I don't like the word
hoax okay I never said I'm gonna burst
onto the literary scene I was in and out
of institutions I was in a group home I
was in foster care I was a ward of the
state this is all out there in the
public record because I went through a
trial and it was all substantiated he
went through everything and it's all
there and someone can do the research so
you don't have to take my word for it
there are interviews with people who
were there in the group home with me who
were my house parents doctors who were
my therapist in my social worker all of
that and the getting published was the
least of it I never actually ever asked
them when hey can you help me get a book
deal I never did that never happened the
work was passed on and JT was offered a
book deal offered an agent it never even
occurred to me it really was like very
accidental but I wanted to do was go
artist to artist with people I admired
and that all of this happened I couldn't
do it any other way it was not possible
as
a very young child I disassociated and I
told these stories in a male voice and
it was the way I self soothed and that
was where I instead of maybe become a
psycho killer I became a storyteller and
they just the need to interact with
other people where you know how Darger
the painter with his Vivian girls he
kept his world internal he just would
paint these portraits of these girls
that were like his Barbie doll portraits
and it was enough for him to keep it for
himself mine needed interaction with the
outside world mine needed someone to
tell them that it wasn't their fault but
of course it couldn't be me because they
wouldn't tell that to me because I had
so much shame I would never ever tell
anyone the little times that I did start
to talk about what was going on I didn't
get that help that I wanted so all of
this came out the way an oyster creates
a pearl out of suffering that creates
his pearl that's valued so it wasn't a
con on the if people want to say it was
this fantastic thing that I pulled over
that was not my intention and I think
that after the reveal or my outing the
media didn't step back and say well why
would somebody go to this extreme to do
all this nobody really looked and I
think I didn't help the situation
because I dug in a trench like everyone
who was writing fake memoir and my work
was always published as fiction it says
fiction all over it you know wouldn't a
fake memoir people and I I don't care
about labels so I'm not judging them but
what people would do they would say look
we're onto you we know the whole truth
they would call a press conference and
they would say okay I'm not really a
pigmy from Antarctica you got me I
apologize I'm sorry I'm going to rehab
which is the American narrative right
I'm sorry I'm going to rehab and I
didn't do that because for me if you
took him I would die so I dug in
deeper against all logic because I
couldn't imagine it's the Tinkerbell
thing how can you it was fighting for my
child for this beings life so I created
kind of like a severe Jean Valjean kind
of limb as a Robb situation of hunting
and that makes people mad so the media
was they were mad and they their
language perpetrator hoax the jig is up
come clean culprit it was very much a
criminal like robbed a bank sold crack
to children kind of language that was
used and that created the echo chamber
and so people who read works that
invited them to be very vulnerable and
perhaps we stimulate their own trauma
which is what I was exploring in my work
they were told that what opened them was
a joke or a hoax and that creates a
trauma of itself and not only that if
they felt attached to this being that
I've murdered
I've killed JT and it was a joke and
they're being told that I'm laughing at
them and I've pulled something over oh
but it was a great wonderful con that's
horrible that's horrible nobody wants to
feel that so it took it had to take time
for the dust to settle and and then
what's beautiful is the felt
authenticity of the work survived what I
gave myself over to and what's available
there and people came back to it and
said wait there's more to the story
which is what happened with Jeff right
what was your reason for wanting to take
on the project and how long did you
spend with it Jeff well my whole life is
nonfiction and new journalism and
there's nothing that I love more than
the truth is stranger than fiction story
when the scandal broke in 2006 when the
New York Times exposed Laura Albert as
JT Leroy I didn't even know about this I
had never heard of a JT Laroy nor had I
read the books and it
the scandal generated just a massive
amount of ink and I read it all friend
of mine turned me on to it years later
and I just had this feeling that there
was so much more to the story than we
were being told and it turned out I was
right and I reached out to Laura Albert
at this point in time she had been
excommunicated by the literary community
she'd been labeled a pariah she'd been
found guilty of fraud in a court of law
for signing the name
JT Laroy on a contract on a movie option
and she was essentially curled up in a
ball I sent her my film the devil and
Dale Johnston that film deals vividly
with the intersection of madness and
creativity and those themes really spoke
to her and she decided at this point to
share her story with me I came to learn
that other documentarians as well as
Hollywood had approached her previously
and she'd said no to everyone but
because of the devil and Dale Johnston
she decided that she was gonna go down
this road with me and that's when we
began Laura looking back from the first
book do you think it could have turned
out any differently there are so many
towels that I knew what was going on
obviously because for me it was being
inside madness and outside and for
instance there's a scene and that's in
the movie where I'm telling Gus where
they're hunting
JT they're now mmm they're hunting Sarah
they were hunting cherry the kid in the
book and he's in the woods and who finds
him and they're the townspeople have
torches and they're gonna tear him apart
and he's revealed
to be something he's not they've
worshipped him and now he's a different
gender and he's completely other than
he's not Laroy and who says what were
you thinking and he says I didn't mean
for any of this to happen and when I was
writing it I was crying and I knew I was
writing the future there was no JT yet
Savannah wasn't in the picture I just
given birth to a baby and I knew I was
sitting there just writing the future
and clearly I knew there was nothing I
could do to change it even that the
title heart is deceitful above all
things deceitful and people after us Oh
deceitful as if I didn't know when I was
titling it
there were towels all the way through I
just didn't have an exit plan because it
was also his life and I wasn't going to
end his life so I just existed in a
duality which if you're schizophrenic
it's a walk in the park but if you're
not it's a difficult life in terms of a
writer writing in a different gender
what are your thoughts on that I mean so
many people say it can be done others
say it can't some say that you can only
do it if you really know that gender
maybe you had a brother or sister that
you were close to what are your thoughts
on that I really feel like we should be
able to create in any voice and anything
we want and some will be effective and
some won't and it's up for the public
who buys it and consumes the work to
sort that out
but until we are we release our shame
and are able to assume the voice of the
other I understand why some people feel
their voices have been co-op
but for instance for me it was nobody
came back and asked me how I identified
nobody and we didn't have the words
gender-variant gender-fluid that wasn't
there and here even though it wasn't
there I was that and I felt that and I
was creating characters that were
clearly gender variant gender fluid it's
all there and I knew the word trans did
not sit and that was a label that was
put on I reserve the right to express
myself by any means necessary Oscar
Wilde said it's not for us to quarrel
with the method that an artist chooses
to express themselves I'm paraphrasing
and I'm down with Oscar you know Laura
what have you learned from making a
living with writing verses film are the
two worlds I made a living doing phone
sex
that's a storytelling I had that is
exactly storytelling that is that's why
I was so successful at it you got it you
absolutely got it and I endure we've so
much of my storytelling from the phone
sex world it and it and I tell the
stories of so many of the clients
because I would take them off the clock
and engage with them what was your
question how to making in the literary
world versus film and television
parallels differences in terms of making
a living getting work out there for me
it's so much of writing I've done for
money was never a motivating factor and
as you know in the arts it's a rarefied
if you actually make money from it it
was quite wonderful when in third grade
I won I could not I went in third grade
I got sixty dollars for being paid for a
story I wrote that was in plays magazine
a protagonist that was male called the
flower that grew overnight
and to get that check for something I
wrote I was addicted um
the difference between television and
writing on your own I love being in a
writers room I love that I love the
camaraderie I love everyone coming
together and working on something if I
could do that all the time I would it
it's my favorite thing I have a friend
that I wrote a script with and I
absolutely when you're with other
writers and they're they're good it's
playing tennis with someone that can hit
the ball back
I hate when you're playing with someone
and they can't get it because if I'm
stuck and I can't get it you know they
can and that'll inspire you to whack the
out of that ball and you're like ah
there's nothing else like it I love it
yeah so um there's there's something you
asked him about the risks yeah and the
one thing about doing this film it
really if you had asked me I would have
wanted to have done this ten years ago
because I knew I needed something like
this there's the immediacy of film that
transcends books it takes people on the
felt experience together we're reading a
book is so quiet and you're alone I knew
I needed something visual and forces you
to have this experience in a sense
because it's so visceral right and I was
so far down a hole and I thought I was
ready ten years ago but I wasn't and he
came at the right time which wasn't my
time it was God's time
spirits time whatever you want to call
it and the fact that I wasn't so
defensive and cautious that I was able
to be available to his work and what
with the beauty of devil and what he was
able to do in film
and he really encouraged me to let go of
my anger resentment and fear and just
let it all be I gave him all the
material the fact that he sorted all
this massive archive that was not
labeled the I had no idea how he was
gonna do it because people say he said
to me he said you know most people have
an a/b story you have a ABCD and I I
couldn't do it I people are saying you
have to write your story I'm like I
can't I can't
and once he got under way I was able to
do it because also he helped me move to
a place of owning everything to like
Daniel resting transparently and because
the writing has really brought me to a
level of integration that some illnesses
need medication to rely on I was able
through this whole process to become
healthier in my body mind and spirit
such as it is it's not perfect but I can
be available now when fans come and it
brings the film brings up a lot because
of the sexual abuse that I talk about
and that was really hard and I wasn't
ready to talk about that ten years ago
it's it's when I watch the film I
tremble it's it's really hard to see
those pictures of me we don't see very
often on some morbidly obese women and
talking about sexual abuse and things
that are hidden from our culture and and
for me I have a lot of shame but it also
invites so many people to come and they
need to talk about it and the fact that
I'm available now in my body to stand
there with them and bear witness and to
share my experience strengths and hopes
such as it is that to me is such a
profound gift that I am so grateful for
and everyone that gave JT time I am so
grateful for them because the truth is
they bought me another day when I called
them through JT Jeremy Terminator when
terminator would call and say he was
suicidal that was my truth I did not
know how I was going to make it through
the day and they bought me another day
and this work has come out of it and I
get the emails from people and they tell
me how it's saving their lives and that
they are able to talk about things that
they never told anybody and I am there
for them now that to me I never would
have dreamt that the fact that I am
signing books under my name there's a
poem by Robert Penn Warren and it goes
this is the process whereby pain in its
past nests may be converted to the
future tons of joy